merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de la
Culture madame la ministre de très
nombreuses personnes ont été choquées
par les menaces que vous avez formulées
à l'encontre des chaînes C8 et c'est
news en menaçant ces chaînes de ne pas
renouveler leur fréquence vous avez bien
sûr heurter les téléspectateurs qui
trouvent une autre manière de s'informer
mais vous avez aussi choqué tous ceux
qui sont attachés au pluralisme de
l'information vous avez scandalisé tous
ceux qui défendent cette grande liberté
constitutionnelle qui est la liberté
d'expression dans une démocratie sur un
sujet aussi sensible que l'information
un gouvernement se doit d'observer une
stricte réserve en aucun cas il ne peut
prendre parti et c'est pourtant ce que
vous avez fait
et en le faisant non seulement vous avez
menacé la liberté d'expression mais vous
avez aussi remis en cause l'indépendance
de l'arcome l'autorité de régulation de
la communication audiovisuelle et
numérique normalement l'arcome devrait
être une autorité publique indépendante
mais par vos propos madame la ministre
vous discréditer et son indépendance et
son impartialité alors madame la
ministre de la Culture allez-vous
observer à l'avenir une stricte
neutralité pour respecter la liberté
d'expression et le pluralisme de
l'information